alors ça ce qu'il a dit là mais c'est
pas bon ça c'est un fou rire pourquoi
tant de jalousie celui-là c'est alors
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a plus aucun
succès déjà
non
très connu français français connu
française une femme française pourquoi
tant de jalousie
elle a été victime actrice célèbre qui a
été victime très populaire une mauvaise
blague une mauvaise rumeur d'un jeune
garçon qui a voulu sur les réseaux
sociaux s'amuser et qu'il a fait
beaucoup de mal ah ouais Turner
actrice de TF1 après célèbre
vraiment
Mimie absolument Mimie Mathy il y a
quelques mois Mimi Mathy a été victime
une terrible rumeur accusant d'avoir
agressé un admirateur dans un centre
commercial avec un rouleau de PQ alors
pardon mais tout est vrai regardez voilà
donc c'est un garçon qui a écrit ça mon
petit frère reconnaît Mimie Mathy et
s'exclame avec enthousiasme Lucas c'est
Joséphine ange gardien oui je fais là
aussi l'interview la réponse de Madame
c'est pas fait attendre elle brandit en
l'air le paquet de 4 papiers toilette
pas de marque Compaq et menace la
mâchoire serrée comme un surtout pas à
parler fort sale mioche de merde bref
faites hyper attention à Mimie Mathy
elle est très agressive les apparences
sont trompeuses mais ça m'étonne pas
non mais c'est une rumeur
ce que je me souviens c'est que quand je
travaillais dans un grand magasin il y a
à peu près 12 ans 12 ans elle était là
mais non et tout le monde et quand elle
arrivait tout le monde disait attention
il y a une assise sur tout personne ne
lui parle personne apparemment elle ne
voulait pas qu'on la fasse chier et donc
elle déambulait donc dans les rayons et
tout le monde était comme ça fallait
absolument pas dire bonjour quoi que ce
soit voilà en tout cas
pardon mais
tant que journaliste j'ai souvent eu
affaire à Mimie Mathy en tout cas à des
gens qui la connaissent elle est elle
est elle a pas la réputation d'être très
sympathique elle a la réputation d'être
très dur d'avoir aucune autodérision et
par exemple il y a cette anecdote qui me
revient au début quand elle faisait de
la scène etc il y avait souvent des
personnes de personnes à petite taille
qui venaient l'applaudir au premier rang
etc et qui lui faisait des signes qui
essayait de lui lui dire on est là on
est là et elle le prenait extrêmement
mal voilà donc moi
[Musique]
des raisons et pas être sympathique mais
non on a tellement pris plein la gueule
au démarrage il faut aussi comprendre de
temps en temps que les enfants
je vous laisse oui pardon c'est surtout
quand tu as des rouleaux de PQ et la max
et c'est pas très gênant ou pas chier à
ce moment là
[Applaudissements]
je pars d'une info pour vous dire que
c'est une fausse info que le gamma elle
sur Twitter elle a dit c'est totalement
faux elle a démonté sur Twitter avec un
tweet qu'on va voir ici et le gamin
derrière également c'est exclusion qu'il
a écrit du bœuf et vous depuis
vous me massez
à faire sérieux une rumeur voilà
prétendue agression de pas avec elle
[Rires]
s'en est pris plein la tête pour rien
donc
je pense pas que ce soit de la jalousie
non plus hein mais je pense que il a
voulu faire connaître comme ça c'est un
gamin c'est ce qu'on appelle des trades
sur Twitter c'est la grande mode de
raconter une des petites histoires sur
Twitter et je pense qu'il a voulu avoir
son heure de gloire c'était très bête et
idiot mais je pense pas que ce soit de
la jalousie mais oui il a été très con
c'est dégueulasse non mais c'était idiot
parce que c'est méchant effectivement
alors moi j'ai pas donné moi la seule
fois où j'ai tourné avec mes Mathieu on
avait tourné pour tellement vrai à
l'époque elle a été adorable pendant les
trois jours ça c'est mon anecdote à moi
mais je ne connais pas plus que ça elle
est voilà elle avait été tous les gens
qui ont vu le premier tweet avec elle a
été méchante et qui l'ont pas vu après
c'est nous qui peut maintenant on doit
fuir les grands magasins Intermarché et
tout c'est l'horreur c'est là mais non
mais pardon
là l'anecdote est drôle mais quand c'est
des choses plus graves et que c'est faux
euh après c'est en tâche la réputation
des deux et c'est vrai que Twitter on a
tendance à tout prendre pour argent
comptant et ça pour le coup c'est
insupportable donc c'est pas un truc qui
était monté par la marque de PQ ah oui
c'est pas une marque compact c'est des
roulements PQ qu'on parle j'ai compris
ça mais parce que du coup on a peut-être
vu